Let's look at the solution
to our LRU quiz.
We had this situation in the cache and
these counters before these accesses.
And now we're performing accesses to A,
B, A, D, and K.
A is the most recently used block.
We reaccess it,
none of the counters change.
We access B,
Bs counter becomes seven from three.
That means that all the counters
above three will be decremented.
Two stays the same.
One stays the same.
Zero stays the same.
So these are the new
counters after Bs access.
Next, we access A again,
this counter becomes 7.
All the counters above
6 are decremented, so
this is really the only change.
Now D is accessed,
this counter becomes 7.
Those above 5 are decremented.
The remaining ones stay the same.
All of these have been hit so far so
nothing has changed in the cache we
still have exactly the same stuff there.
The only change will be when
we access K which is in this.
So now we need to choose who goes out.
And the one that goes out is
the one whose counter is zero.
So H is replaced by K.
The other blocks are remain
the same as they were and
this is the final answer for this quiz.